الوزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي يثمار بني
كثير انه سيواصل واقتحاماته للمسجد الاقصى
في تحدي الرئيس الوزراء بنيميله نياهو بعد
تعوده للعاهل الاردني بالحفاظ على الوضع
القائم في المسجد الاقصى بالقدس المحتله
وقال ابن كثير احد زعماء التحالف
الصهيونيه الدينيه المتحالفه مع جونياهو
بانه لن يكف عن ذلك لان اسرائيل ليست
محميه لاحد حسب تعبيره وقال انه رغم
احترامه للملك الاردني الى انه سيواصل ما
وصفها بالصعود الى جبل الهيكل جاء ذلك في
حديث اذاعه الاسرائيليه الرسميه صباح
اليوم الاربعاء وغدتها زياره رئيس الوزراء
همم
ولقائه العاهل الاردني في العاصمه
الاردنيه عمان
كشفت صحيفه صيلها يوم ما ان توليفه اقصى
اليمين المتطرف برئاسه لليمينه تنوي
التصديقه على مخططات لبناء 18 الف وحده
سكنيه الاستيطانيه جديده في الضفه الغربيه
خلال الاشهر القليله المقبله اضفت الصحيفه
المواليه لليمين الحاكم ان الحكومه
الحاليه تستعد للتصديق على الاف المخططات
لبناء وحدات الاستراليه جديده كانت
الحكومه السابقه برئاسه الثنائيه ايرلابيد
ونفتن بنت اوقفتها خلال عامين ونصف من
حكمها اضافه الصحيفه ان حكومه اقصى اليمين
الحاليه تنوي عقد مؤتمر فورينا المجلس
الاعلى للتخطيط والبناء في الضفه الغربيه
لتصديق على الاف المخططات والشروعه في
تنفيذها
داخل الهدول المصري
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد وانت تتابع هذه
التصريحات لابن كثير او حتى هذه المتعلقه
بالمخططات الحكومه اليمنيه ما الذي يجعل
من كثير وهذه التسريبات الصحفيه يعلو
صوتها في ظل وجود بنيمنتنياهو من المفترض
ايضا في الاردن همم التاكيد على الوضع
القائم والتهدئه
بدايه التحذيرات الدوليه والعربيه عمرها
ما رضعت اسرائيل ولا يبدو انها ستكون
قادره على رجعها في ظل حكم هذه الحكومه
المغاليه في تطرفها لذلك تغولها وتغول
سياستها سواء على الصعيد الاستيطاني او
غيره او تجاهها المسجد الاقصى واضح انها
تنذر باقادم الايام بانها ستتسع وتزداد
بلغبير في حديث الاذاعه كان واضح بانه
يتحدى حتى رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو عندما
يقول انه سيواصل اقتحاماته للمسجد الاقصى
وياتي ذلك في هذا التوقيت بعد يوم واحد من
زياره الياهو الى الاردن وتعهده للعاهل
الاردني بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم هناك
ثانيا هذه المخطط الاستيطاني الهائل الذي
يتحدثون عنه نحو 18,000 وحده سكنيه في
ارجاء الضفه الغربيه واعاده ما وصفوه
بالنشاط في المستوطنات التي فاخلاقها عام
2005 اثناء حكومه اري ال شارون بعد
الانفصال عن غزه يشير الى ان هذه الحكومه
تعمل وفقا منهجيه ووفقه برنامج معد سلفا
وهو بالفعل بانها حكومه اقصى اليمين
المتطرف والمتدينين والمتزمتين وهناك هيئه
التفكير تضع المخططات تعرف كهيله التي
تشرف على ذلك كله وتمدها بهذه المعلومات
فواضح ان الموضوع ليس موضوعا عبثيا وانما
ضمن مخططات واسعه لماذا يرتفع الصوت بهذا
الخصوص عن غيره بان كافه اركان هذه
الحكومه هي همم من الواضح بانها تؤيد هذا
التوجه وهم بالنسبه لهم في الانتخابات
الاخيره انتقلوا من مرحله اداره الصراع مع
الفلسطينيين الى مرحله حسمه وفقا شروط
الاسرائيليه في اسرائيل انتقلت من حكم
اليمين قال رغماتي الذي الى هنا ثانياه
لعده سنوات طويله ومثلته الحكومه السابقه
ايضا والى مرحله اليمين التوراه العقائدي
الذي يعتبر الضفه الغربيه ارض اسرائيل
وانه حر التصرف فيها وخطته الاستراتيجيه
هي ضم هذه الضفه ولا يعترف بوجود وجوده
وطني للشعب الفلسطيني فيها ولكن العمري
مدير مكتب الجزيره من رام الله شكرا الزين
لك